dienstag 21
april 14 uhr hauptbahnhof wien gleis 10
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
zeigt sich bei einem pressetermin
erfreut über unterstützung diesmal nicht
vom sondern für das bundesheer mit dem
heutigen tag gibt es die rot-weiß-rote
freifahrt für unsere soldatinnen und
soldaten die im zusammenhang mit dem
norovirus im einsatz sind wie so lange
nicht das gesteck ganz großes dankeschön
zu sagen an die österreichischen
bundesbahnen die diese solidarität und
anerkennung unseren soldatinnen und
soldaten zeigen und auch an alle
verkehrsverbünde auf eine unkomplizierte
art und weise durch die schleife durch
das tragen der uniform wir gezeigt dass
man im einsatz ist ein dankeschön an die
solidarität die hier seitens der öbb und
der verkehrsverbände für unsere
soldatinnen und soldaten gezeigt wird